des danses des jeux des jeux de toutes
sortes pour les plus petits et des jeux
d'avant aussi pour les plus grands à
travers ses activités ludiques
il s'agit de sensibiliser les enfants
aux règles de la vie en société
faire reculer les incivilités constatées
lors des jeux entre les élèves les
enfants aiment jouer donc on s'est dit
qu'on ne peut pas leur en parlez nous
des civilités comme ça va donc on a on
s'est servi des jeux on les observer
durant léger et on leur a dit par
rapport aux tensions que vous faites
dans les jeux vous pouvez tout vous
tapez 2 moi j'ai gagné tu as perdu
vous êtes un civil on a souligné élodie
voilà c'est ainsi voilà de fond ou ceux
dits de romo des choses comme ça va pas
relogées on leur apprend les bonnes
manières et de la bouche même des
enfants
les incivilités auxquelles ils se
livrent entre eux doivent cesser pour
plus de respect mutuel comme thème
général est parfois il me donne des
coups de pied et des coups de poing
quand les gens se bagarre il n'y a pas
un peu nous on veut nous s'il ne faut
pas taper les grippés
faire des croche-pieds bas on se donne
des coups pieds on se donne des coups
coin
d'idées il ya des gens qui disaient
bonjour
c'est tout et qu'il faut faire alors my
fights et tous à savoir à quand son tour
patiemment fait aussi partie des règles
ne pas tricher s'excuser autant de
notions que les 1800 élèves présents à
cette journée ont révisé aujourd'hui
tout en s'amusant
[Musique]